اربعه ايام مضت على هول الفاجع والكارثه
مستمرون معكم مشاهدينا في تغطيه العربيه
للكارثه الانسانيه التي خلفها الزلزال
المدمر الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا اذا نحن
معكم في اليوم الرابع من هذه الماساه ومع
مرور الوقت تتضاءل معه فرص العثور على
ناجين تحت الانقاض المهدمه
وفي حصيله جديده لضحايا الزلزال قفزت
الحصيله لنحو سته عشر الف قتيل في الوقت
الذي يعمل فيه رجال الانقاذ في سباق مع
الزمن لانتشال ناجين محتملين محاصرين تحت
انقاذ الاف المباني التي انهارت بفعل
الزلزال ففي تركيا اعلنت اداره الكوارث
والطوارئ ان عدد وفيات الزلزال ارتفع الى
اكثر من
12,300 قتيل فيما ذكر المرصد السوري لحقوق
الانسان ان حصيله ضحايا الزلزال في سوريا
ارتفعت الى
358 قتلى
انا عندك لا تخاف
طلع لي
لا تخوف تمام
معلش معلش يا خالو معلش وانا
معلش
اعلنت منظمات والصحه العالميه انها ستقوم
بنشر فرق من خبراء الانقاذ وسترسل امدادات
طبيه الى تركيا وسوريا
انها كارثه كبيره انتشر اثرها على نطاق
جغرافي واسع لدينا الكثير من الناجين الان
في العراق في ظروف سيئه للغايه لدينا
اضطرابات كبيره في امدادات المياه وانقطاع
في الوقود والكهرباء ووسائل الاتصالات
واساسيات الحياه هناك خطر حقيقي لحدوث
كارثه ثانويه قد تتسبب في ضرر لعدد اكبر
من الاشخاص من الكارثه الاوليه اذا لم
نتحرك بنفس الوتيره كما نفعل الان في
البحث والانقاذ
الهزات الارتداديه سلسله من الزلازل تحدث
بعض الصدمه الرئيسيه الاكبر على الصدع بين
الصفائح التكتونيه
تحدث بالقرب من الصدع بحسب العلماء حيث
حدثت الصدمه الرئيسيه هي جزء من عمليه
اعاده التعديل بعد الانزلاق الرئيسي في
الصدع بين الصفائح
تنتج عن التغيير المفاجئ في الاجهاد الذي
يحدث داخل وبين الصخور ليس لها عدد محدد
الا ان تواترها ينخفض مع الوقت تستمر حتى
ايام او اشهر او سنوات بعد الهزه الاساسيه
تم تسجيل اقوى هزه ارتداديه بعد الزلزال
الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا على انها زلزال
بقوه 7.5 درجه وتلاتها مئات الهزات
الارتداديه في المنطقه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ابويا هلا طالعنا
امي واختو دائما مع ضيوف العربيه الكرام
من اكثر من منطقه سواء في الشمال السوري
وايضا من الجنوب التركي لنعاين ونطلع على
جديد التفاصيل وواقع المواطنين المتضررين
بفعل الزلزال نذهب اولا الى ريف حلب ومعنى
ان هناك الصحفي احمد ابو لؤي احمد اهلا بك
معنا في سياق هذه التغطيه جديد الاخبار
التي تاتينا من شمال سوريا وتحديدا من حيث
انتم
نعم تحياتي عزيزتي
بعد ماضي ثلاثه ايام ومع بدايه اليوم
الرابع من ضربه الزلزال المميت محاولات
مستمره وما زالت من قبل رجال وفرق الدفاع
المدني انتشار العالقين وما زالوا احياء
ومنهم من وافته المنيه
حتى حتى الان احصائيات القتلى ما زالت
ترتفع وترشح بالارتفاع في الايام القادمه
حيث
تجاوزت
1780 قتيل اما بالنسبه لاعداد الجرحى
تجاوزت ال 2900 اصابه بالنسبه للابنيه
التي دمرت بشكل كلي وصل عددها الى 418
مبنى طبعا غالبيه هذه الابنيه
في منطقه
جنديرس بريف عفرين شمالي حلب اما المباني
التي دمرت بشكل جزئي وصل عددها الى 1300
مبنى
وبالنسبه
للابنيه التي تصدعت اعدادها بالالاف
طبعا
احدى المناطق والبلدات التي تحظى باولويه
في عمليه الانقاذ اليوم
نعم تماما تماما بالضبط حيث وصل عدد
الابنيه
220 مبنى
تهدموا بشكل كلي ما زال هنالك مئات
العائلات تحت الانقاب فرق الدفاع المدني
بمسانده بعض شبان المنطقه وبعض الفصائل
التي اتوا الذين اتوا من اجل مساندتهم ما
زالوا محاولين شاهدين من اجل
اخراج من تبقى سواء كان على قيد الحياه او
وفته المانيه طبعا المناشرات ما زالت حتى
الان من اجل ادخال المساعدات على كافه
الاصعده
كمرتبه اولى اليوم الدفاع المدني بحاجه
الى اليات بحاجه الى
جرافات ادوات من اجل
انتشال اكبر عدد من
الجث العالقه تحت الانقاض حتى الان طبعا
حتى الان لم احمد الامم المتحده في اخر
تصريحاتها تحدثت عن ان 5% فقط من الشمال
السوري تم التغطيه من قبل فرق الانقاذ
وجهود انقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه من هم تحت
البيوت المهدمه هل الواقع يفسر هذا
التصريح هل فعلا يعني هناك العديد من
الابنيه التي مازال يمكن ان يتم الحصول
والوصول الى جثامين ربما او حتى احياء
منهم
نعم عزيزتي تماما بالضبط هذه التصريحات
صحيحه حتى الان خمسه او عشره بالمئه فرق
الدفاع المدني نهائي الفرق الوحيده
المتواجده هنا وامكانياتهم بسيطه جدا اصبح
كما ذكرت منذ قليل شبان المنطقه عدد من
الفصائل
بمساندتهم يعني اوضاع ماساويه بشكل كبير
طبعا معبر باب الهوى يوم امس صرح الجانب
التركي انه تم تفعيله لكن حتى الان لم
يدخل اي مساعدات انسانيه طبعا
هنالك
المعلومات متضاربه فيما يتعلق بالمعابر
مفهوم بانه كان المعبر غير مفعل بفعل
الطرق التي تؤدي اليه التي تضررت بفعل
الزلزال لكن تاتي المصادر وخصوصا لمصادر
العربيه او يوم امس انا معبر باب السلامه
والراعي مفتوحان لدخول المساعدات اذا ماذا
عن المع اخرى
تماما ذكرت يوم امس انا بجميع الاستقافات
ان هنالك معبر باب السلامه معبر الحمام
عبر باب السلامه يقع في مدينه الشمال حلب
ايضا معبر الحمام يقع في المنطقه المنكوبه
جنديرس
ومفعلين لكن لا يدخل ابدا عن طريق تلك
المعابر اي مساعدات انسانيه
لان الاعتراف الوحيد بادخال المساعدات
سواء من الامم المتحده او الجانب التركي
هو من المعبر الذي يعتبر الشريان الوحيد
في شمال غرب سوريا هو بعض باب الهوى وكما
ذكرتي ان المعبر بدايه بدايه الضربه ضربه
تم اغلاقه
خوفا من الزلازل والردات وغيرها لكن
امبارح يوم امس تصريح الجانب التركي
لتفعيل المعبر لكن لم يتم تنفيذ اي اي نوع
من اشكال ادخال المساعدات طبعا على ذلك
هناك مساعدات وصلت نعم تحدث عن المساعدات
هنالك مساعدات وصلت الى مناطق النظام
السوري لكن مع الاسف بفعل الحصار السياسي
الصراعات بين فصائل المعارضه التي مازالت
وبين النظام لم يدخل حتى الان بين الفصائل
وبين نظام السوري من اجل ادخال مساعدات عن
طرق النظام السوري الى شمال غربي سوريا
حتى الان يعني
معلومات تفاصيل احمد بانه قد يتم التنسيق
بين الطرفين على مستوى اكبر يعني اليوم
نتحدث عن ماساه فلا مجال للسياسه هنا
نعم نعم اليوم بعيدا عن السياسه بشكل كلي
الحزب هو انسان على المنطقه كشمال غربي
سوريا سواء شمال حلب او منطقه ادلب حتى
الان لم يتم التنسيق يعني سافيدكم باي باي
معلومات جديده
ان حصل اي تنسيق مع النظام او القوات
النظام السوري من اجل مداخل من اجل ادخال
مساعدات لو بجزء بسيط لمسانده المدنيين
لمسانده فرق الدفاع المدني المتواجدين وما
زالوا
محاولي جاهدين لاخراج العالقين تحت
الانقاد
اعدادهم يقدر بالالاف من الاشخاص او مئات
العائله طيب احمد اليوم في ريف حلب وفي
شمال غرب سوريا لمن تحملون مسؤوليه تعطيل
او عدم ايصال هذه المساعدات انتم عالقون
اليوم النظام السوري والجانب التركي لمن
تحملون بالدرجه الاولى
طبعا
متواجدين هنا يحملون الجانب التركي كمرتبه
اولى مرتبه اولى
لان هنالك عدد من المعابد كما ذكرت مفعله
يعني وادخال المساعدات لا يعيق او يؤرق اي
احد يعني بشكل مباشر تدخل المساعدات لكن
لا نعرف الاسباب حتى الان توقف ادخال
المساعدات لشمال غربي سوريا مع الاشرف طيب
واحمد كيف يفسر دخول سيارات الى معبري
السلامه والراعي سيارات تحمل جثمين قتلى
سوريين قتلوا في المدن التركيه وتم نقلهم
لدفنهم في سوريا كيف يفسر امكانيه وصول
سيارات
ولكن عدم وصول لمساعدات
يوم امس وتجاوزت 320 جسمان وكان ذويها من
طرف الشمالي غربي سوريا بانتظارهم يعني هو
الغريب عن الشارع يتكلم بهذا الامر
يعني جساميل سوريين
[موسيقى]
قتلوا في
زلزال الذي وقع طبعا بتركيا واثر بدوره
سلبا على مناطق شمال غربيه سوريا
الجثمين ترسل بشكل مباشر ومستاجره عن طريق
يعني
المدنيين محتارين نوعا ما لماذا جانب
التركي لا يساهم في
فتح الممرات الانسانيه من كافه المعابر من
اجل ادخال المساعدات حتى الان يعني لا
تفسيرات واضحه اليوم اوضاع المدنيين
الثقل وخوف هنالك الالاف ما زالوا تحت
اغصان الزيتون في العراء ومنهم من جلس
باحوال عربيه لربما عندها اقربائهم لانها
تعتبر اقل عرضه للخطر باي ردات
[موسيقى]
للهزات طبعا اوضاع كما ذكرت يعني بعموم
مناطق شمال غرب سوريا هي اوضاع قاسيه جدا
على كل حال احمد يعني سننقل هذه التساؤلات
التي قلتها قبل قليل وتسائلت بها لي
ضيوفنا من الجانب التركي في سياق هذه
التغطيه واليوم هل هناك مازال من مباني
قايله للسقوط اخلاها ساكنوها ام قاتنوها
ام ماذا
نعم بالضبط
هنالك
يعني 1300 مبنى هذه المباني دمروا بشكل
جزئي وهنالك الالاف من المباني تصبعت وتم
اخلائها بشكل مباشر لانها غير اليه عائله
للسكن لكن سيتم وضع لجان من قبل المجالس
المحليه بالشمال الغربي سوريا ومراجعتها
من اجل الكشف عن تلك المباني ان كان ان
كان بعضها السكن من اجل عوده الاهالي وان
كان بعض الاخر
للسكن وهذا الامر سيتم في الايام القادمه
بالتاكيد سنكون معكم في سياق هذه الساعات
للتغطيه المفتوحه عبر العربيه لنعرف
المزيد والمزيد من التفاصيل حتى لحظه شكرا
لك من ريف حلب الصحفي احمد ابو لؤي
لا صوت يعلو فوق صوت اهات السوريين في
معبر باب الهوى وفي كل جغرافيا سوريا
المكان لا يتسع سوى لبكاء ونحب الاحياء
وهم يستقبلون جثث امواتهم
الطرق سالكه فقط لنقل من فارق الحياه اما
من نجا من الكارثه ربما لن ينجو من
تبعاتها
لا مساعدات لا فرق انقاذ تصل رقعه الشمال
السوري الذي مزقته الحرب قبل ان تعبث به
اقدار الطبيعه
المعلومات بخصوص نقل المساعدات عبر المنفذ
متضاربه منظمات الاغاثه التابعه للامم
تضرر الطرق المؤديه الى المعبر رغم وجود
مستودعات اذا حصيله ضحايا الزلزال ترتفع
الى 16 الف قتيل نذكر بحصيله الضحايا حيث
ما زال هناك المئات من هم معالقون تحت
البنايات وتحت ركاب وحطام الابنيه المهدمه
التي سقطت فوق رؤوس قاتلها منذ ثلاثه ايام
حيث دخلنا اليوم في اليوم الرابع لهذه
التغطيه المفتوحه لمتابعه تداعيات وتبعات
هذا الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب فجر يوم
الاثنين الجنوب التركي كان مركز في الجنوب
التركي ومن ثم ايضا وصل ارتداداته واثره
الكبير الى الشمال السوري حيث ان الشمال
السوري هو المتضرر الاكبر بالدرجه الاولى
حيث قالت الامم المتحده بان فقط 5% تم
تغطيتها من قبل فرق الانقاذ حتى هذه
اللحظه بالتالي مازال هناك المزيد من
الابنيه وايضا ابنيه ايله بالسقوط ولكن تم
اخلائها من قبل ساكنيها وحتى الان عداد
الموتى يتضاعف ويزداد لحظه بلحظه في كل
يوم وفي كل ساعه يتزايد عداد الموتى
وتتضاءل معها فرص البحث عن ناجين اليوم
عندما نتحدث عن اليوم الرابع هنا
التساؤلات عن الوصول الى ناجين هنا تحدث
المعجزه
الانسان اولا
سياسه جانبا في شمال غرب سوريا
الامم المتحده دعت الى تسهيل ايصال
المساعدات الى المناطق الخاضعه لسيطره
فصائل المعارضه في سوريا
والمنكوبه بفعل الزلزال
المساعدات الانسانيه المخصصه لشمال غرب
سوريا تعبر من تركيا عبر باب الهوى الذي
تضرر جراء الزلزال
ضعوا السياسه جانبا ودعونا نقوم بعملنا
الانساني اذ لا يمكننا تحمل الانتظار
الدمار في حلب وحمص واللاذقيه وفي شمال
غرب البلاد هائل وعلينا الوصول الى هناك
من اجل تقييمه
نامل في استئناف نقل المساعدات وان نكون
قادرين على عبور الحدود يوم الخميس
والشاحنه جاهزه للمغادره
انها ازمه فوق ازمه وليس هناك معدات للبحث
والانقاذ ولا معدات طبيه ولا ادويه كافيه
هذا ما دعى اليه المنسق المقيم للامم
المتحده في سوريا
المصطفى بن لمليح
قبل الزلزال كانت غالبيه السكان بحاجه الى
مساعدات انسانيه
والكارثه الاخيره
راكمت ماساه فوق الاخرى
نزوحا من نوع اخر تعرض له السوريون مره
اخرى بعد زلزال المدمر الذي ضرب شمال
سوريا يكون ملجئهم خيام نازحي الحرب
السوريه في محيط ادلب
[موسيقى]
منى لم تختبر النزوح طوال السنوات الحرب
سوريا الا ان رعب الزلزال دفعها لهجر
منزلها المدمر لتلجا الى من يشاركها
الماساه باختلاف الدافع منى والعديد ممن
نجوا من الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب تركيا
وسوريا
استنجدوا بنازح الحرب في ادلب ليحتموا في
خيامهم
منه والله لا غرض ولا شيء ولا شيء
الله هيك بعدهم وحنان علينا واعطونا اغراض
من عندهم
زلزال القرن فاجا السكان في وقت باكرا من
الصباح ليههربوا من منازلهم بملابس النوم
حفاه مشهد مرعب عشه هذا الاب مع اطفاله
الاربعه حصل يعني صعب جدا جدا يعني
كانه يوم القيامه يعني شغله كبيره كتير
وقعت البنايه
وهز قويه كتير كتير طلعنا حفيانين
بالرومات وبالمي والمطر يعني وضع صعب جدا
جدا
نازحوا الحرب الهاربون من القصف ومدافع
النظام السوري احتضنوا النازحين الجدد فقد
اشتركوا في خراب المنازل والرعب من الموت
[موسيقى]
بقى احنا سوينا اللي علينا جمعنا بعض
هالنساء بعضها الاطفال جبناها لعنا على
الخيام طلعنا برات خيامنا وحطيناهم
وسوينا اللي علينا يعني لفيناهم دفيناهم
ما بين طلع الضوء
تعددت الاسباب والموت واحد لتكون الخيام
جامعه المصائب السوريه ان كانت بفعل
الطبيعه او الانسان واحتمال النجاه الضعيف
اذا عمر العربيه
اعلنت المملكه العربيه السعوديه عن طلاق
الجسر الجوي لاغاثه متضرري الزلزال في
سوريا وتركيا وافاد مراسل العربيه بان
طائرتين سعوديتين اتجهتا الى مطار اضنه
التركي وهي محمله بمساعدات طبيه واغاثيه
وتحمل على متنها ايضا فرق اسعاف وانقاذ
متخصصه مراسل العربيه اضاف ان الجسر الجوي
سيستمر خلال الفتره المقبله ياتي ذلك فيما
بلغ حجم التبرعات للمتضررين اكثر من 80
مليون ريال
[موسيقى]
كنا نياما عند حدوث الزلزال فجاه بدات
الاهتزازات على هذه الحاله استيقظنا احتضن
اطفالنا وقمنا بالركض ونحن ندعو الله كانت
الاهتزازات لا تنتهي حقيقه شيء يصعب شرحه
الله لا يبتلي احدا بهذا المصاب عندما
غادرنا البناء بدات الهزات الارتداديه بعد
عده دقائق حينها ركضنا في الشارع وكان
الجميع في حاله هلعه كان شعورا سيئا
للغايه
عندما جلبت اقربائي من منطقه نورداك في
ولايه غاز عنتاب بعد حدوث الزلزال كان
امامنا ثلاث حافلات تقل الجيش والشرطه كان
هناك هطول للامطار والثلوج لذلك ساعدونا
في الوصول استغرق الطريق سته عشره ساعه
علما انه يستغرق عاده ساعتين
الا من برلين وجئت لمساعده اصدقائي هنا
وانقاذ الناس ابني ايضا جاء معي للمساعده
وهو يعمل مع الاوراق المتطوعين انا اسكن
في الطابق الاول عند حدوث الزلزال خرجنا
الى الشارع بسرعه في منطقه ينيبي كان
مشهدا مخيفا
والد زوجه طيفون ايدوغان وزوجته عائشه
واولادهما ثلاثه كانوا يعيشون في هذا
المبنى وجميعهم تحت الانقاض حاليا لم
نستطع الوصول اليهم حتى اللحظه ما تزال
اعمال الانقاذ مستمره ونحن لم نفقد الامل
بعد
نذهب الى اسطنبول معنا من هناك جواد جيك
الباحث في الشان التركي استاذ جواد اهلا
بك معنا في هذه التغطيه سيد جواد هل
تسمعني هل انت جاهز معنا طيب يبدو ان
استاذ جواد ليس جاهزا معنا حتى هذه اللحظه
سنعود اليه في سياق هذه التغطيه ربما نذهب
الى الصور مباشره الان لكي نتابع معكم هذه
الصور المباشره التي ننقلها لكم هذه الصور
عمليات الانقاذ التي ما زالت مستمره حتى
هذه اللحظه حيث الجرافات تحاول ازاحه
الحطام والركام وهناك تركيز طبعا وفق
البيانات والمعطيات للاهالي والمواطنين
حول بنايه ما في اي منطقه بان هناك قد
يكون تحتها اشخاص على امل ان يكون منهم
ناجون هذا اولا بالنسبه للاولويات ايضا
يتم التركيز على اكثر البلدات والمناطق
تضررا مثلا اذا تحدثنا عن الشمال السوري
جنديرس في عفرين في حلب هي من اكثر
المناطق تضررا بالتالي التركيز عليها بشكل
كبير جدا اما اذا تحدثنا عن بلده
الاصلاحيه في غازي عنتاب في تركيا فهي من
اكثر المناطق تضررا بالتالي هي منطقه
منكوبه بالكامل فهذه هي الصور التي لم
تهدا طبعا عمليات الانقاذ لم تهدا وحتى
متطوعين ومن وصل لمحاوله المساعده وتقديم
المساعده بابسط الامكانيات وحتى الاليات
التي تم الاستعانه بها من قبل المساعدات
مثلا نائب رئيس التركي قال امس امس بانه
اكثر من 100 الف شخص يشاركون في الانقاذ
حتى هذه اللحظه اما بالنسبه للخوض البيضاء
وفرق الخوض البيضاء التي تقوم بعمليات
الانقاذ في مناطق شمال غرب سوريا هي التي
تخضع لسيطره المعارضه ما زالت حتى هذه
الساعه عمليات الانقاذ مستمره يعني حتى
يوم امس مساء كنا نسمع عن قصص للوصول الى
ناجين وانتشال ناجين من تحت الانقاض كان
هناك اخبار مبشره وعلى امل ان يتم الوصول
الى ناجين اخرين ولكن عامل الوقت عامل مهم
جدا يقال بانه في كل ساعه تاخير نتحدث عن
50 ق يوازيها 50 قتيل خصوصا وان عامل
الوقت مهم جدا لمن وقعوا وسقطوا تحت ابنيه
الركام وما زالوا تحتها نتحدث عن اليوم
الرابع على التوالي فبالتالي تتضاءل
الاعمال وتتضاعف
عاجلا ام اجلا سيحدث زلزال بقوه 7.5 درجه
في هذه المنطقه
سرعان من دفع علماء تابعون لهيئه المسح
الجيولوجي الامريكيه لنفي امكانيه ان
يتوقع من يسمون انفسهم علماء التنبؤ او
غيرهم بتوقيت او مكان الزلازل اما تفسير
ما حدث فبسيط ان المنطقه التي وقع فيها
الزلزال موقع نشاط متكرر حيث تتلاقى ثلاث
صفائح تكتونيه الزلزال القوي لم يمثل
مفاجاه لاي عالم زلازل تركيا منطقه زلازل
معروفه وليس غريبا ان تتعرض لزلزال بهذه
القوه
بحسب هيئه المسح الجيولوجي الامريكيه يمكن
الاعتماد على خريطه مخاطر تضعها الهيئه
لحساب احتمال وقوع زلزال كبير في منطقه
معينه خلال عدد معين من السنوات وهو ما
استند عليه في الغالب صاحب التغريده
المثيره ولكن الاهم بالنسبه للعلماء هو
البحث في امكانيه ابقاء المباني قائمه
للحفاظ على ارواح ساكنها وليس توقع توقيت
ومكان الزلازل عن السمان العربيه
وهذه الخوض البيضاء التي تتحدث عن مواصله
عمليات الانقاذ في سوريا وسط ظروفا صعبه
بعد 75 ساعه على الزلزال المدمر الخوض
البيضاء تتحدث بان عدد ضحايا زلزال سوريا
سيرتفع بشكل كبير بسبب وجود مئات العائلات
تحت الانقاض حيث ما زالت عمليات الانقاذ
مستمره وسط الظروف الصعبه طبعا لا ننسى
بانه كان في موجه ثلجيه قاسيه ضربت هذه
المنطقه من البلاد وبعد هول وفاجعت الصدمه
وما زالت الابنيه حتى الان هناك ابنيه
ايله بالسقوط تتساقط وتتداعى بفعل التبعات
واثار الزلزال نذهب لنسمع الموقف الامريكي
وجديده حيث قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
انطوني بلينكن قال ان حجم الخسائر في
الارواح جراء الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا
وسوريا صادم ومروع حقا وذكر ان الولايات
المتحده اكثر من 150 من عناصر البحث
والانقاذ في تركيا وان واشنطن سيكون لديها
المزيد لتعلنه في الايام المقبله بشان
الكيفيه التي ستواصل بها دعم الشعبين
التركيه والسوري خلال مرحله التعافي من
الدمار
هزات ارضيه عنيفه في اجزاء واسعه من تركيا
وسوريا ادت الى فتح المجال حول طرق قياس
الزلزال وتطورها على مدار فتره متباعده
فكلما ضرب زلزال عنيف بلدان ودول مختلفه
فالى اي مدى قد يكون هناك اختلاف فعلا بين
مقاييس هذه الزلازل ونتابع في التقرير
التالي
هزه ارضيه تحصد ارواحا وتخلف مناطق منكوبه
في اجزاء واسعه بين تركيا وسوريا ومع كل
كارثه تتنوع طرق رصد قوه الزلازل وتتطور
من بينها الاكثر شهره مقياس ريختر وهو
مقياس كمي يقيس شده الزلازل من خلال تحديد
مقدار ارتفاع اكبر موجه زلزاليه تم رصدها
على مسافه محدده من المصدر الزلزالي
ظهر في ثلاثينيات القرن الماضي مستندا في
تصميمه على الخصائص الجيولوجيه لولايه
كاليفورنيا فقط
كان يقيس شده الزلازل المتوسطه التي
تتراوح بين ثلاث الى سبع درجات الا ان
زلزالا قويا في جنوب كاليفورنيا ادى الى
تطويره ليقيس الزلازل التي تتجاوز 7 درجات
مقياس العزم الزلزالي تكمن دقه مقياس
العزم الزلزلي في مقدار الطاقه المنطلقه
منه عند مص قد تم تصميمه ليحل محل عده
مقاييس بما فيها مقياس ريختر ويوفر هذا
المقياس قياسا اكثر تناسقا للزلازل مهما
كان عمقها الى جانب التنبؤ بحوادث تسونامي
وغيرها من المخاطر المرتبطه بالزلزال
مقياس ميركالي ويصف مقياس مركالي معدل
الزلازل من حيث تاثيرها ويستخدم الارقام
العاديه لقياس القوه بينما يستخدم الارقام
الرومانيه للتعبير عن تاثير الزلازل
ويتدرج مقياسه لرصد الزلازل التي تتراوح
قوتها من درجه واحده الى اثنتي عشره درجه
مقياس وكاله الارصاد الجويه اليابانيه
يقيس حجم الزلازل باستخدام وحدات شندو في
اليابان وتايوان فقط ويعتمد على نفس اليه
مقياس ميركالي المعدل لكنه يقيس حتى سبع
درجات فقط
وهو تقييم قامت مصلحه المساحه الجيولوجيه
في الولايات المتحده بتطويره عام 2010
للفصل في جدليه ما اذا كان مقياس القوه او
مقياس حجم الزلزال هو الفيصل في مدى
تاثيره وتقوم هذه التكنولوجيا بتقييم مدى
توزيع الهزات وعدد الاشخاص والمجتمعات
المتضرره والوفيات والخسائر المحتمله علي
السمان العربيه
وفي جديد المعلومات على لسان الخوض
البيضاء عدد الابنيه المنهاره جزئيا في
شمال غربي سوريا وصل الى اكثر من
1300 مبنى وهناك الالاف من المباني كما
تقول الاخوه البيضاء تصدعت في شمال غربي
سوريا بسبب الزلازل وان عدد الضحايا في
سوريا سيرتفع بشكل كبير بسبب وجود المئات
من العائلات ما زالوا تحت الركام فعمليات
الانقاذ ما زالت مستمره وسط ظروفا صعبه
وبعد مرور اكثر من ثلاثه ايام على هذا
الزلزال المدمر الذي راح ضحيته اكثر من 16
الف قتيل فاذا جميع فرق الخوض البيضاء
تقول بانها تقوم حاليا بكامل طاقاتها
لانقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه من المتضررين تقول
بان هذه المهمه شاقه عند اخذ الموارد
المحدوده بعين الاعتبار خصوصا وسط
المناشدات بالحصول على المزيد من
المساعدات وعندما نسمع عن كلمه مساعدات
هناك شقان يتعلقان في مساله المساعدات
الشق الاول يتعلق بالمساعدات المطلوبه
ضروريا الا وهي الاليات والمعدات خصوصا
وانا منطقه شمال غربي سوريا
تفتقر لهذه الاليات التي تعتبر مهمه في
تسريع عمليه البحث بالنسبه
المباني وايضا الابنيه المنهاره كما تقول
ايضا الخوض البيضاء بانه انهارت عده
مستشفيات بعد الهزات الارضيه بالاضافه الى
انه الوضع بشكل عام عندما نتحدث عن النظام
الصحي فهو نظام منهج جدا في هذه المنطقه
هذه المنطقه لا ننسى بانها تعرضت لحرب على
مدى عقد من الزمن تعرضت لهجمات سواء هجمات
روسيه وايضا هجمات من قبل النظام السوري
على مدى كل هذه السنوات الماضيه بالتالي
هذه المنطقه لا يمكن لها ان تحمل وان
تتحمل اكثر مما خلال هذا العقد ما الماضي
وهذه السنوات والفتره السابقه من حروب
وايضا صواريخ وبراميل متفجره سقطت في هذه
المنطقه فالنظام فيها نظام الصحي منهك
اصلا وحتى الان يدخل متطوعون لمحاوله
انقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه ممن علقوا تحت الارض
اليوم فقط هناك تركيز اكثر على انتشال
الجثثامين على الاخذ بعين الاعتبار بان
العلم والمنطق يقولان بان الان اصبح الناس
في عداد الموتى منهم تحت الارض ولكن يبقى
الامل موجود والبحث عن معجزه ما يمكن ان
تحصل اذهب معكم الان الى
التركيه موفد العربيه من هناك محمود شكر
محمود اهلا بك معنا في هذه التغطيه منذ
ليله امس وانا اشاهدك واتابعك في هذا
المكان تنقل لنا الصوره
والصوره جديد الاحداث اين انت الان يعني
انتقلت من مركز الايواء
هذا المكان الذي تحول الى مركز ايواء لنقل
ومساعده
المحتاجين والمتضررين بفعل الزلازل الان
ما الجديد لديك
محمود هل تسمعني
طيب
الاتصال كان مقطوعا نحن انتقلنا كما اسفت
بالحديث من المركز الاساسي لتقديم
المعونات العاجله في وسط المدينه الى صوره
التي هي تتحدث عن نفسها الان داخل وسط
المدينه هنا مثل بعض الوقت اشار للبعض من
الذين يشرفون على اعمال رفع على انقاذ انه
يوجد حوالي 15 شخصا نزل تحت الانقاذ سالنا
الان الاشخاص ماذا يفعلون كان الجواب الى
انه بالامس كان هنالك عدد من الاصوات التي
تدلل على انه يوجد احياء داخل هذا المبنى
وتحت هذه الاسقف المنهاره ولكن قالوا منذ
بعض الوقت الى ان الاصوات
ذهبت منذ ساعات
نذهب ايضا الى النقطه الاخرى هنالك كيف هم
يرفعون هذه الاسقف المنهاره هذا فعل هنا
ابني اذا صح التعبير على الايدي وعلى
الجنود وعلى المعاول وعلى المعدات
التقليديه بالمقلب الاخر للصوره اذا ذهبت
مع المصور يعني هي مشهديه حرب كانها
الجرافات
والرافعات التي ترفع الانقاض والركام هنا
سيارات الاسعاف في المقلب الاخر هي تدخل
الى قلب المدينه على عجاله من امرها وهي
هذه العجاله ليست الان انما على مدى
الساعه والمدى يعني كل الوقت تشاهدين
السيارات تدخل وتخرج القوافل بالمقلب
الاخر للكميونات التي تنقل
الجرافات وتنقل الحفارات هنا في هذا
المبنى يعني اعد حفاره اثنين ثلاثه اربعه
اربعه في هذه الجهه الى ايضا هنا
معدات متخصصه لرفع
الابنيه او لرفع الاسطح المنهدمه كما
نشاهد نذهب الى تلك النقطه لربما ماذا
يعني البعض يقول انهم يحاولون العثور على
احياء ولكن بعد هذه الايام
الاربعه نعلم اذا كان هنالك من احياء
البعض يقول كما اشرت معك الى خمسه عشر
مفقودا لا زالوا تحت الانقاذ في هذا
المبنى اذا كان امكن يعني بالتاكيد نحن
نتابع معك المشاهد محمود ومحمود هؤلاء
يعني يبدو على عندي مشكله بسماع السؤال
وبسمال
طب خلاص الكلمه لك محمود لتنقل لنا الصوره
كامله
نحن ذهبنا الان ماذا يجري هذا اذا امكن
اذا سمحت
في احياء
هناك صوت ساذهب بالسؤال الى احد الاشخاص
محمد في
حماد يا الله يا الله
[موسيقى]
مباشره على امل الوصول الى ناجين وان تحدث
هذه المعجزه اليوم لليوم الرابع
وبقوه يسابقون الزمن يسابقون الوقت
يسابقون يعني كل ما هو كل ما هو ممكن
يستعملونه حتى يصلوا الى طفل او طفله او
شخص ومنهم البعض من هو يعني كما نشاهد
الان هو يعني تحت هذا الانقاذ
البعض يقول انهم كانت الاصوات حتى ساعات
الفجر تخرج من هذه النقطه ربما كان هنالك
من احيانا كما نشاهد يعني انا الان اشاهد
ايضا الاسطح وهنالك غرف من
اساس غرف البيت يعني كما نشاهدها الان من
هذه الفجوه ويظهر ان هذا الاساس اساس غ
لربما ان هذه هذه
فرش لربما يكون ان هنالك من احياء في هذه
الغرفه يعني عمليات نعم ساعود معك الى الى
الى الى السؤال عمليات البحث وفق المشاهد
التي نتابعها مباشره توحي وتشي نوعا ما
بانهم يعني اقتربوا ربما من الاشخاص
العالقين اما احياء او موتى هل هذه
المعلومات دقيقه وفق مراقبتكم عن قرب
محمود نعم نعم هم قالوا انهم في هذا
المكان منذ الامس سمعوا اصوات حتى الصباح
كان هنالك اصوات او حركات تدلل على وجود
احياء وهم يقومون بهذا الجهد الان بهذه
النقطه لاننا اذا اخذنا الصوره مع المصور
على هذه البنايه التي تقريبا دائرتها
حوالي 100 متر يعني بشعاعها
الشاحنات والكاميرات نجد ان الجهد هنا
يتركز على هذه النقطه وهذا المحل مما يعني
ان هنالك يعني نسال الله ان يكون هنالك
احياء بعد هذه الايام الاربعه بالنسبه الى
الاحياء او بالنسبه للذين تحت الانقاض حتى
هذه الساعه لم اتمكن من الحصول على
معلومات الدقيقه بقضيه الارقام انه هل تم
عدد الذين تحت الانقال حتى هذه الساعه
البعض يقول هنا يوجد في هذه البنايه البعض
الاخر يقول في الحي الاخر البعض الاخر
يقول في الحي الثالث ليس هنالك من معلومات
دقيقه او رسميه عن الذين هم تحت الارقام
بالامس حتى تمكننا من الوصول الى هذه
النقطه واشتز عدد من الحواجز كان الجل
اننا وصلنا الى المدينه تركز مع ساعات
الليل معنا في النقل المباشر عن تقديم
المساعدات وتقديم لانه حتى في الليله يمكن
للصوره ان تعكس حقيقه يعني عمل الانقاذ
الان
نزول في المدينه وتحديدا في هذه الابنيه
وكما كان البعض يقول ان هنالك ابنيه
باكملها قد سويت مع الارض وصحيح كما نشاهد
بهذا البناء واذا اخذنا ايضا الامنيه التي
حول هذا البناء
بكاميرا المصور نجدها انها متصدعه يعني
كلها غير صالحه للسكن هنالك نقاش بين من
هو هدم او غير هدم او اصابه الذره كل هذه
الابنيه التي تشاهدينها هي غير صالحه
اطلاقا ان يسكن بها من جديد او هنالك
خطوره من الدخول فيها اليها لان كل الاسس
التي عليها هي قد اصابها الضرر واصابها
التلف الجسيم يعني مشكله
بالسكن اليها او العوده اليها لذلك
نكون هنا بهذا الرصد علنا ان تكون ذلك باب
للخير وان يكون هنالك من احياء بهذه
النقطه وان بعد اليوم الرابع او اليوم
الخامس كنت قد التقيته صباحا بفريق تونسي
متخصص بعمليات رفع الارقام وكان ياخذ برهه
من الوقت للاستراحه وكان السؤال الاهم هل
برايكم بعد اربعه او خمسه ايام هنالك من
امل لوجود ناجين فقال انه يمكن ان يكون
هذا صحيحا وهذه المساله مبديه اذا صح
التعبير على العوامل او مبنيه على الظروف
التي يكون فيها هذا الشخص تحت الارض فاذا
كنا مثل هذه الظروف الان نخرج يطلب مني
الخروج من فوق السطح عله ان يكون في مشكله
سنخرج سريعا نعم نعم اوكي اوكي
سنخرج من هذه البقعه
ان يكون
العوامل المحيطه بهذا الناجي تحت الانقاض
ان يكون عنده فسحه من المكان متر او مترين
تحت الانقاذ وعندي تتوفر له بعض من الماء
يمكن له ان يبقى لايام عديده او يمكن له
ان يبقى ايضا باسبوع اذا كانت الامور او
الظروف
متاحه وهو يستطيع ان يتكيف ولكن
وهذه نقطه مهمه
يعني هذه نقطه مهمه تتعلق بالتساؤلات
اليوم حول المده الزمنيه التي يمكن ان
يبقى فيها الفرد على قيد الحياه نامل بان
تخرج من بين الركام وبين الحطام حياه مره
اخرى وحياه جديده اليوم لاشخاص عالقين
خصوصا في هذه البنايه التي سنكون معك في
سياق الساعات المقبله لنعاين جديد
التفاصيل فيها من ادعيه من التركيه مفرد
العربيه محمود شكر شكرا جزيلا لك مستمرون
مع في هذه التغطيه ونشير الى ان اديمان هي
احدى المقاطعات العشر التي تم تصنيفها على
انها مناطق منكوبه بعد ان اعلنت تركي عن
عشر مناطق واولايات مقاطعات منكوبه بعد
الزلزال المدمر واعلنت حاله الطوارئ لمده
ثلاثه اشهر اذهب معكم الان الى اسطنبول طه
عوده اوغلو الباحث في الشان التركي ينضم
الينا استاذ طه اهلا بك معنا في هذه
التغطيه اليوم هناك تحميل للجانب التركي
المسؤوليه بالدرجه الاولى لعدم وتعطيل
ايصال المساعدات لشمال سوريا لماذا لا
يساهم اليوم الجانب التركي من اجل ادخال
المساعدات
تحياتي لك في البدايه واستاذه المشاهدين
بالامس ليله امس كان هناك تصريحات من وزير
الخارجيه التركي مولود شاويش اولو تحدث عن
هذا الموضوع وتحدث بانه سوف يتم فتح مع
بارين حدوديين مع سوريا وتحدث بان الطرق
في سوريا والتي مؤدي الى سوريا هي مغلقه
بسبب الزلزال وهي معطله وتحدث ان هناك
خاصه الباب المتعلق او القريب من باب
الهوى جلبه وهو هذا يفتح وفقا باتفاق اممي
كما تعلمين هو هناك اتفاق خاصه مع الامم
المتحده عصام مساعدات منذ سنوات يعني
تركيا اكد على لسان الوزير الخارجيه هي
مفتوحه ولكن هناك لا توجد مساعدات يعني
هذا الموضوع هو منوط بالدرجه الاولى للامم
المتحده يعني تركيا في حال وصلت مساعدات
حتى نتحدثات على الرغم من ان هناك
العلاقات غير جيده بين انقره والنظام ولكن
ممكن اذا وصلت مساعدات عبر الجو ارسالها
من تركيا حتى الى مطار حلب على كل الاحوال
يعني هذه التصريحات هي جاءت نعم بعد هناك
اتهامات وجهت الى تركيا ولكن
السؤال الاهم والابرز اين الامم المتحده
مما يحصل حاليا في سوريا تحدثنا عن سابقا
وقلنا ان كل المساعدات وكل الاهتمام كله
هو جله
لتركيا خلال اليومين الماضيين وخاصه كانت
يعني دوليه وامميه ولم يتم الحديث بشكل
وافي وكبير عن الوضع في سوريا
طه يعني هناك القول بان سوريا لم تطلب
اليوم بشكل رسمي تفعيل ما يسمى بالحمايه
المدنيه من الاتحاد الاوروبي وحتى تقوم
الامم المتحده بارسال المساعدات الى هناك
فقط يعني هذا اجابه على سؤالك
نعم نعم يعني هناك يعني حاليا تعلمين ان
نظام هناك يعني هو مدعوم من بعض الدول من
ايران من روسيا هناك يعني تقدم مساعدته
ولكن الكارثه كبيره جدا نحن نتحدث عن
تركيا تركيا كدوله كبيره ولها تجربه مع
الزلازل وهناك استراتيجيه
قامت او عدتها منذ سنوات يعني التعامل مع
هذه الازمه ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه تواجه
تحديات كبيره وهذا ما تحدثت به عن قفا ما
بلكي النظام السوري وخاصه بعد الاحداث
الاخيره والحرب وايضا يعني هناك نتحدث ان
النظام هو لم يبسط يده او سيطرته بشكل
كامل على كافه الارض داخل سوريا طيب استاذ
طه اليوم ما الذي تخشاه مفهوم بانه كان في
هناك ازمات وتازم وحروب بين الاطراف لكن
ما الذي تخشاه هذه الاطراف وحتى تركيا من
ايصال مساعدات نتحدث عن مساعدات بالدرجه
الاولى انسانيه لمساعدات عسكريه هذه المره
ولا اسلحه ولا غيره
نعم حاليا تركيا هناك لا تخشى شيء وخاصه
يعني نتحدث ان الوضع هذا الوضع انساني ولا
توجد هناك السياسه مفرده في هذا الموضوع
اطلاقا وخاصه هناك تضافر وهناك تسارع عدد
كبير من دول العالم وتضامنه مع الانسانيه
وان كانت في تركيا او حتى في سوريا
الانسان هو نفس الانسان ولكن حاليا اعود
واكرر لك بان هناك غياب اممي وغياب دوله
عن الوضع في سوريا وهذا لافت للغايه على
عكس ما نراه حاليا في تركيا حاليا في
سوريا هناك حتى يعني مغيب الاحداث بشكل
كامل او نصحب تعبير نوعا ما تعتيم وهذا
بمساعده النظام الذي دائما يتحدث ويطمئن
الجميع بان الامور تسير على ما يرام
والعكس صحيح على عكس ما نراه تركيا هي كل
شيء مفتوح على الساحات يعني قبل قليل
ملفاتكم كان يتحدث من اضيع مان يعني ويرى
صوره بشكل واضح ما نراه حاليا في سوريا
طيب استطاعه هل في اصوات في الداخل التركي
اليوم تحاول اعاقه او منع ايصال لمساعدات
او التعاون مع الجانب السوري خصوصا بعد
هذا الزلزال
يعني انا التصور اعتقد حاليا الاهتمام
التركي ان كان رسمي وحتى شعبي بشكل كبير
هو على الداخل التركي ولكن من دون شك يعني
هناك بعض الاصوات ان كانت من المعارضه هي
ترفض لا اقول رفض مساعدات للشعب السوري
ولكن هناك خاصه ان الازمه والماساه كبيره
في الداخل التركي انت تم الحكومه التركيه
في الجانب السوري وموضوع
ماساه او كارثه سوريا هذه ممكن تكون لها
حسابات وتستفيد منها المعارضه وبعض القوه
التي هي تحاول قدر الامكان او تتربص
للحكومه التركيه يعني اليوم تركيا طول
الاولويه للداخل المحلي التركي قبل الحديث
عن ايصال مساعدات الى الجانب السوري
صحيح نعم يعني الحريقه الاهتمام بشكل كبير
في الداخل التركي حاليا نتحدث عن الوضع في
تركيا الى حتى هذه اللحظه ما زال نحن
نتحدث عن يعني استمرار عمليات الانقاذ 73
ساعه هناك محاولات كبيره لانقاذ ما يمكن
انقاذه هناك عمليات يعني ان كانت
يعني توفير مسكن توفير ايواء توفير يعني
هناك خدمات صحيه للمواطنين هناك عجز
التعبير على الرغم من توافذ عدد كبير من
دول العالم نلاحظ هناك دول العربيه دول
اوروبيه دوليه تصل الى تركيا ولكن الى حتى
هذه اللحظه بعض المناطق ما زالت يعني تصعب
او يصعب الوصول اليها بسبب بعض العوائق
والعراقيل المناخيه وايضا اللوجستيه في
المنطقه لذا تركيا تحركت خلال الساعات
الاخيره الماضيه فيما يتعلق بالنظر في
موضوع
عفوا في موضوع سوريا ولاحظنا ان هناك
تصريحات من قبل مسؤولين وعلى راسي وزير
الخارجيه تحدث عن ان تركيا هي جاهزه
لتقديم المساعده للشعب السوري من خلال فتح
المعابر والسماح لاي مساعدات قد تمر الى
تلك المناطق ولو ان زلزال جاء مفاجئا رغم
التحذيرات التي سبقته وكان هول هذه
الفاجعه مفاجا هل كانت الحكومه التركيه
مستعده له
يعني تركيا قبل قليل كان هناك استراتيجيه
وضعتها خلال سنوات للتعامل مع هذا ولكن
كانت الاستراتيجيه مركزه بشكل كبير على
مدينه اسطنبول ونتحدث ان تركيا منذ عام 99
والى حتى هذه اللحظه كان هناك خطوات قامت
بها على الرامنه كانت خطوات بطيئه وخاصه
فيما يتعلق بعمليات التنظيم فيما يتعلق
بعمليات البناء مدينه اسطنبول الى حتى هذه
اللحظه نتحدث عن ان هناك العديد والمئات
انصح التعبير الالاف من المباني هي معرضه
للزلزال اذا حصلت هناك هزه قويه على الرغم
من هناك خطوات قامت بالحكومه خلال الاعوام
الاخيره الماضيه فيما يتعلق بالبنيه
التحتيه ولكن المنطقه التي شهدت زلزال هي
كانت بعيده كل البعد عن الاهتمام الحكومه
خاصه بانه هذا المنطقه هي نائيه وغير يعني
جاهزه ان كانت فيما يتعلق بالمستشفيات
فيما يتعلق بالمساكن واهميه هذه المساكن
لذا كانت الصدمه هنا والمفاجاه التي يعني
واجهت الجميع هنا داخل تركيا لان تركيا
معذ
ل كبيره على صعيد ميداني وايضا على صعيد
سياسي شكرا جزيلا لك من اسطنبول لطه
الباحث في الشان التركي شكرا لك
[موسيقى]